la parole est à neutre et que les gens
voici pour le groupe l'est républicain
j'avais la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur président michel collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation monsieur
le ministre des distributeurs bras de
l'alimentation et le travail de nos
agriculteurs prétextant de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
or la vitalité de nos territoires passe
par le renouvellement générationnel du
monde agricole et par la sécurisation
des pme transformatrice et c'est tout
l'intérêt de valois et galim 2 alors que
la négociation commerciale annuelle
entre la grande distribution et les
industriels et les filières agricoles
qui se termine le 1er mars sont
particulièrement tendues il est attendu
deux choses premièrement que le résultat
de ces négociations soient
scrupuleusement analysés par vos
services que nous puissions savoir si la
matière première agricole en fait les
frais alors que la loi prévoit que son
prix ne soit pas négociable quand on
entend un géant de la distribution vente
et la côte de porc 15 euros vin et la
baguette à 29 centimes on peut
sérieusement en douter
deuxièmement il faut que la loi soit
strictement respectée je vous ai déjà
alerté sur la nécessité d'un arsenal de
sanctions suffisamment dissuasif car
objectivement la médiation me permets
pas l'évitement des pratiques abusives
on ne peut accepter que les industriels
répercutent leurs hausses de charges en
diminuant le prix de la matière première
agricole de la transformation seul un
contrôle très strict de ces dispositions
et vous vous êtes visiblement engagé à
les multiplier permettra d'accompagner
les agriculteurs et pme vers la
rentabilité face à l'explosion des coûts
de production sur la filière porcine en
un an les prix payés aux producteurs ont
diminué de 14% alors que les coûts de
production ont augmenté de 27% s'il est
confirmé que des pratiques illégales
perdure il va falloir passer des
contrôles aux sanctions afin de
dissuader les récalcitrants le
gouvernement ne peut avoir la main qui
tremble monsieur le ministre vous
engagez vous avant cette échéance du 1er
mars à sanctionner les contrevenants et
rendrez-vous publics les chiffres des
résultats de ces négociations
pour vous répondre la parole les
communistes de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur de normandie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur la réponse est oui
à vos deux questions la rémunération
c'est la mère des batailles vous l'avez
dit c'est la mère des batailles pour nos
agriculteurs mais tout simplement parce
que il n'est pas possible de faire
d'agriculture sans agriculteur il n'est
pas possible d'avoir d'agriculteurs sans
rémunération donc c'est la mère des
batailles et donc toute l'énergie que
nous avons mise au sein du gouvernement
mais sur ces bancs puisqu'une grande
majorité d'entre vous avez voté la loi
et galim de toute l'énergie que nous
avons mises dans l'instauration de cette
fois et gagné 2 qui est une loi de
régulation nous la mettrons également
dans sa mise en oeuvre ça veut dire que
concrètement nous démultiplions
l'ouverture d' enquêtes sont jacques
depuis le 1er janvier c'est plus de 250
enquêtes qui ont d'ores et déjà été
ouverte sur les négociations en cours
c'est-à-dire sans même atteint attendre
la fin des négociations
deuxièmement ce serait une tolérance
zéro dès lors que ces enquêtes auraient
montré de manière claire que des actions
étaient illégales c'est à dire que la
loi et galim de n'auraient pas été
respectées je voudrais saluer les
services de bercy sous l'égide daniel
spagnou relâchés notamment la directrice
de la dgccrf et ses équipes qui sont à
pied d'oeuvre main dans la main avec le
ministère pour faire en sorte que ce
soit tolérance zéro et je ne veux pas
être plus clair troisièmement oui pour
publier l'ensemble de ces sanctions pour
que les consommateurs les français les
citoyens sachent ce qu'ils jouent le jeu
et ceux qui ne jouent pas le jeu et je
terminerai juste en disant à toutes
celles et ceux qui refusent encore
d'appliquer la loi et galim de ce qu'ils
sont en train d'organiser c'est la
délocalisation de notre agriculture la
délocalisation de notre souveraineté
agroalimentaire et je suis sûr que vous
comme moi nous nous battrons avec force
avec determined détermination pour les
empêcher de faire cela en tout cas soyez
assurés de notre mobilisation
ce bâti
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
affirmations
mais je suis quand même inquiet vous
avez témoigné un engagement pour la
filière porcine par un plan de
sauvegarde de 270 millions de cette
année ce qui permet cette année de ne
pas retrouver les agriculteurs dans la
rue mais qu en sera-t-il l'an prochain
lorsque nous ne serons plus en période
électorale
[Musique]